SENATE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
WILL BEGIN NOW. UM WE'LL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON. WE'RE
HOLDING THIS COMMITTEE HEARING
IN ROOM 112 IN THE STATE CAPITAL
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS THE OLD
CAPITOL BUILDING. I ASK THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 112 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. UM I BELIEVE THAT WE DO
HAVE SUFFICIENT MEMBERS TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM, SO MADAM CHIEF
COUNSEL, WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL? FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. UMBERG
UMBERG HERE WOKE ALAN ASHBY,
CABALLERO DURAZO. HERE SO HERE
LAYERED LAYERED HERE, MEN MEN
HERE, YELLA NILO. HE WAS HERE.
STERN STERN HERE, UH, WAHAB. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM. ALL RIGHT, UM,
AND WE HAVE ONE BILL BEFORE US,
UM SENATOR Ó BEFORE WE, UH
PRESENT S¼ B. UH, 479 LET ME
RECOGNIZE THE CHAIR EMERITUS OF
THE STATE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. UH SENATOR HANNAH.
BETH JACKSON IS HERE WITH US
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
UM I WANT TO NOTE THAT WE WILL
ALLOW TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK. AFTER THE
PRIMARY SUPPORT. I'LL INVITE
OTHER SUPPORTERS TO STATE THEIR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
THAT WOULD DO THE SAME FOR THE
OPPOSITION. AFTER WE HEAR FROM
THE SUPPORTING OPPOSITION. WE'LL
TURN TO COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE IF YOU WISH TO FURTHER
EXPOUND ON YOUR POSITION ON THIS
BILL OR ANY OTHER BILL, YOU CAN
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE
USING ONE OF THE METHODS
DESCRIBED ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. ALL RIGHT,
UM SENATOR DE RASO. CLOSURES
THANK YOU, MR CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS DELETED THE CONTENTS
OF S¼ B 479 AND REPLACED IT WITH
A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO MY S¼ B
567 FROM LAST YEAR. THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO ADDED AN URGENCY
IN ORDER TO CLEAN UP S¼ B 567
PRIOR TO THE BILL GOING INTO
EFFECT NEXT MONTH. AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS, S¼ P 567 DEFINED
WHICH OWNERS ARE AUTHORIZED TO
EVICT THE TENANT IN ORDER TO
MOVE THEMSELVES OR QUALIFYING
FAMILY MEMBERS INTO A UNIT
PURSUANT TO CIVIL CODE SECTION
19 46.2. THIS MEASURE WAS
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND WITH ME TODAY ARE
DEBORAH CARLTON, CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION, AND
ELIZABETH JOLENE KI¾M
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR. PICO
CALIFORNIA THERE ANY QUESTIONS?
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? GO AHEAD.
TESTIFY. GOOD AFTERNOON. UH
THANK YOU, SENATORS. UH, THANK
YOU, SENATOR Dð RAZO FOR MAKING
THIS TECHNICAL CLEANUP. WE WORK
WITH HER LAST YEAR ON SENATE
BILL 567, AND WE APPRECIATE THE
MINOR CLEANUP, BUT VERY
IMPORTANT. UH, APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ELIZABETH KI¾M
PICO, CALIFORNIA ALLEGED
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS KIND OF BILL. WE JUST HAD A
CALL WITH Dð Ó J THIS MORNING.
VERY EXCITED TO START THE
ENFORCEMENT. UH, TENANTS ARE
MILLIONS OF TENANTS ARE WAITING
FOR THIS BILL TO HELP PROTECT
THEM FROM HOMELESSNESS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. UH, SEEING NÓ
ONE ELSE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S TAKE, UH, ANY
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION TO S¼ B
THREE. EXCUSE ME. S¼ B 479
SEEING NÓ ONE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. ALL RIGHT, LET'S
COME TO THE COMMITTEE. UM I SEE
THE LION IS LAID DOWN WITH THE
LAMB. SO UH, QUESTIONS QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NÓ
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBER
SENATOR THERE. SENATOR LAIRD
MOVES THE BILL. UM ALL RIGHT.
UH, WE'LL GO AHEAD AND WE WILL
CALL. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR ROSSO? I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT, AND I VOTE
. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL THE MEASURE IS S¼ P 479.
THE ACTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
UMBERG. UMBERG. I WILK. WILK. I,
ALAN. ASHBY. CABALLERO. DURAZO.
TORAO I, LAIRD LAIRD, I MIN MIN
I NELA NILO I STERN. WELL. THANK
YOU. SIX ALRIGHT. UM THERE'S 66
I VOTES AND NÓ NÓ VOTES, BUT
WE'RE GONNA PUT ON CALL. WE'LL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL HERE FOR,
UH, FOUR MINUTES. SO THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR BEING SO RESPONSIVE
TO MY REQUEST. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUSSO. THANK YOU,
SENATOR JACKSON FOR BEING HERE.
SHOULD GET SO EASY. YEAH IT
YEAH. RIGHT IT SENATOR DE ROOS,
SENATOR OSSO.
I SEE SENATOR ALLEN IS HERE.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE ROLL
FOR, UH, SENATOR ALLEN. MADAM
SECRETARY, IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL.
HØI ALAN HERE, ASHBY. AND I
CABALLERO. STERN. WHAT TO BE
CLEAR. SENATOR ALLEN VOTED I
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. AND SO THAT'S
SEVEN. WE'RE GONNA PUT BACK ON
CALL HERE FOR A FEW MORE
MINUTES. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ALLEN. I.
ROLE. PLEASE CALL THOSE WHO HAVE
NOT YET VOTED. ASHBY. HØI ASHBY.
I CABALLERO. CABALLERO. I STERN.
HØI W IY. ALL RIGHT. HOW MANY IS
THAT IN FAVOR? 1010 0. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL
AGAIN FOR TWO MINUTES. YES. MR.
WHICH I DON'T OH, THEY'RE ACROSS
THE WAY. I YOU KNOW WHAT? WE'RE
NOT GONNA WAIT FOR HIM. WE'LL
WE'LL GIVE IT TWO MINUTES AND
THEN SHUT IT DOWN. AND YOU KNOW
WHAT? LET'S SEE. CAN YOU CALL
SENATOR STERN'S OFFICE AND SEE
IF HE WANTS TO. IF THIS IS A
THING FOR HIM, WE'LL HOLD THE
ROLL OPEN, BUT I DON'T THINK HE
CARES. I'LL CHECK ON IT RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU. SO YOU GO BACK
THROUGH NÓ MATTER WHAT ONE MORE
TIME AND IF HE'S NOT HERE, THEN
I'LL CLOSE IT DOWN.
WELL, I GOT ALL RIGHT. UH, LET'S
OPEN THE ROLL FOR ONE FINAL
TIME. PLEASE. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THOSE WHO HAVE NOT
YET VOTED. SENATOR STERN. ALL
RIGHT, UH, THE VOTE. LET'S
ANNOUNCE THE VOTE. THEN. 10 TO
0. ALL RIGHT. THE BILL IS OUT.
UH AND WE ARE ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU.